i've never uh met this young lady i've
never chatted with her but i
sure have rooted like crazy watching her
on the slopes she is the seven time
olympic and world ski champion that you
watch so much
on nbc and the tokyo olympics i should
mention begins next summer on nbc
peacock will have a role as well as it's
your home for the olympic games always
enjoy watching at work on behalf of this
country and the way that she holds
herself in doing so the seven time
olympic and world ski champ
michaela schifrin here on the program
how are you today
hi i'm i'm doing okay how are you
i'm doing fine i know i i kind of
started the interview with that question
and that's my normal default even though
i read the new york times story on you
saying that
you know when you're asked that question
you don't quite know how to answer it
these days
but that's my job my definition i'm
still taking it as like
small talk just starting
trying to it is that where have i found
you where are you on the planet
right now i'm uh at home in edwards
colorado right now
three days away from shipping off to
europe or
um what we hope to be the start of the
ski season the race season
right and and i guess um and that's
that's one of the major reasons why
you're on today
about keeptheflamealive.org
and what is going on uh in the world
with covid19 you know we're all focused
clearly about the tokyo games and how
it's affected
but the beijing games in 2022 this is
pretty significant as well and
obviously this involves your late father
as well i want to give you the floor
here on what you'd like everyone to know
about
if you don't mind yeah well you know
during this time like you like you
mentioned obviously
tokyo um has been majorly affected by
the pandemic but it
it's no it kind of snowballs no pun
intended into
the fall upcoming olympics and it i
think it might go
you know beyond beijing even but um
for the winter athletes who are also
prepa
trying to prepare for the upcoming race
season this
this season um competing but then also
next season which is the olympic season
it's
these these two years are incredible
um for training and getting prepared and
having our athletes be the
the best prepared we can be going into
the olympics
and with the pandemic the snow sports
industry was
hit incredibly hard like i think pretty
much across the board all industries
were hit
but definitely having to close down
pretty much everything in snow
sports several months earlier than
expected and
you know having to shut down usc and
snowboard just had to shut down
everything like everyone else and it
it took a huge hit and then you know
kind of waking up in the face of
a pandemic and trying to how do we
manage
running everything again and you know
you have
a lot of extra costs a lot of extra
travel
travel with including quarantine which
adds 14 days to travel
and and meals and lodging for athletes
that usb and snowboard would
have has been covering you have testing
costs just
just doing covid testing um was going to
add
i think the number i saw was an extra
million or more to
the budget so what back in the spring
af it was a little bit in conjunction
after my dad
um passed away a lot of people were
contacting
my family and asking where they could
donate and
we didn't really have an answer in the
immediate weeks following his
his passing and in the celebration of
life but
we sort of started talking with some
really big supporters on the u.s ski and
snowboard and
some some people who have donated in the
past and
came up with this idea of starting a
resiliency fund that would bridge the
gap that we've lost in f
in other fundraising events um that at
extra costs that athletes are facing
person and that
usc and snowboard is facing in order to
help
all of the athletes across the board
train and
you know use this fund to bridge the gap
in costs
and try to get us all to be able to keep
training and competing heading into the
olympics and be fully prepared
as we otherwise would have and
then the it's also it's kind of a
two-fold goal there's another side of it
which is
hugely important and part part of why we
named it in honor of my dad was the
message of resiliency
and especially right now i think it's a
really important message to be spreading
that
we all all of us everybody no matter
what you do
no matter what your job is no matter
your political backgrounds
everybody needs to come together and um
and you unite really and unite behind
this message of
resiliency of that you can still be
strong in the face of
disaster of heartache and pain
and just terrible things that are going
on
in everybody's life right now that are
going to leave scars for a long time to
come
but um you know if i give you some
strength maybe you can
give me some of your strength and
together we can
get through it and that's that's where
keep the flame alive came from you can
there's more details that
keeptheflamealive.org like you had
mentioned but
that's where that whole message came
from and i think
the fundraising is hugely important for
athletes on the u.s ski and snowboard
but
a message of spreading resiliency that's
for me in a lot of ways that's equally
as important it's a mental battle
it has been for me this entire summer
and there's been
we've done some interviews with i have
an interview up on the website a couple
other
several other usq and snowboard athletes
have some really great interviews and a
lot of great insight to share about
resiliency
we're planning to just continue sharing
stories and continue sharing that
message
because whether you're able to donate or
not i think everybody can
can use a little something that will
uplift them
especially right now
keeptheflamealive.org
michaela schifrin here on the rich eisen
show i lost my dad in december
so i'm sorry no no i'm sorry for your
loss my my dad was 82
um and you know uh it was it was still
sudden
um your dad was younger and obviously it
was it was still sudden but
just hearing you say you know i can give
you strength you can give me strength
that was my strength
in the immediate aftermath it really
does mean a lot you know
it really does and i had not lost a
parent and i really didn't know what it
was like
until it happened and i would always
hear that you know like what can i do
for a friend and like well just you
reaching out are you doing x y and z
really means a lot and it did yeah
you know it it really did and for you to
combine that along with obviously
something
that you're known for and uh you know
obviously your your dad inspired you in
it really is beautiful
it's beautiful thank you well we're
we're all
everybody involved with getting the
resiliency
fund you know started and
up and running i'm super grateful and
i'm really proud of it we're all
really proud of it and i'm excited
everybody the the response has been
amazing it's only
you know been publicly launched for a
little over 24 hours and people have
been
i'm so proud of how
we've all we've gotten the message
across because
i didn't want it to be something like oh
you know please donate
even though even though we're looking
for donations that i wanted it to be
like i'm we're we just have to help each
other here
and like you said yeah people reaching
out saying what can i do
often times there's not something they
can do from
for me i'm like you can't do anything
but
thank you for sending a message that
that alone is
you know that just gave me something to
look at and made me smile a little bit
and that was the most you could do at
this time
well i mean you just keep doing you um
michaela you know uh
i know um you know on your twitter and
social media you've been you've been
talking about life events and
you know you'd probably get a lot of
stick to skiing and
a lot of you know couple of those stick
stick to just be in usa and you know
you've got a voice you've got you've got
something going on but just also know
this you know i've got a
i've got a seven-year-old girl at home
um
and my wife put her on skis literally uh
at age three um which is
one which is which is exciting because
especially since her dad loves apres ski
more than ski
like my problem michaela is stopping you
know what i mean like i have an issue
stopping that's my concern is how to
stop
but you know but us being able to show
you know her
you know you uh means a lot it really
does so you should know that as well i
know i'm not asking any questions i'm
just kind of having a conversation with
you
wow that's really nice that's really
nice of me to say thank you
no and we're seeing pictures of you and
your dad right now we're seeing some
video of that
when did you first get on skis yourself
when did that happen um
i was two and a half ish
um it was in my driveway actually my mom
and dad i did this with my brother who's
two and a half years older than i am and
taught us how to ski first in our living
room they put on those tiny little
plastic skis and just had us like
walk around the living room and just get
used to the feeling and then
took us out in a sled towed us up to the
top of the driveway and had us
kind of ski down it and then then we got
to graduate to the mountain and then
we couldn't hold either one of us back
once we got there
that's it that's it so you know you're
saying there's a chance for my daughter
it's basically
certainly wasn't in the driveway here in
los angeles i'll i'll tell you that
so you're heading off to germany and
then so what's your plan like what do
you want to happen obviously the the
virus
has its own say clearly but what what
are you
what are you hoping for uh from as a
through line from
from here all the way to to to i guess
the end of this year even with beijing
and mine
yeah um yeah i'm hoping
you know looking at quite a few of the
other sports right now
and how they are operating um you know
basketball formula one
a lot of a lot of sports are rising to
the challenge finding a way to
include fans in a different way than
before but still including fans
and being able to compete and actually
have their games and continue with the
playoffs and
race and that's what i hope for ski
racing is that
you know our season starts on october
17th it's supposed to start on october
17th and i'm hoping that
um our the whole world cup circuit will
all be able to come together
and you know i talk about the message of
resiliency it's really about everybody
just saying hey
this is this is less about me and more
about us
all being able to have our sport and to
do our sport in the midst of a pandemic
and the pandemic's not going to go away
before we
are supposed to have our first race of
the season so we have to manage it
and do the best we can and it's great to
see so many sports
you know promoting masks and have it
getting the testing and
getting their athletes in a bubble and
trying to trying to be aware of
the global climate while you're still
doing what you're
you know hoping to do in your own little
world
because it sets an example for everyone
else and for all the people out there
saying you know we can't shut down our
economy and do this and then like this
is how we continue
and sports and business and work in our
jobs
and could keep the economy going this is
how we're going to do it so
it's it's not like an either or
situation where we gotta
find a way to show up today and make it
happen today
given our current circumstances and i
think that's what i hope for ski racing
is that we find a way to do that me too
in terms of resiliency all you got to do
is look at jamal murray and the nuggets
right there in colorado right
that's right that last game oh god
i cannot believe the final shot that was
like i tore my heart out and just
smushed it on the floor hey but it's
look but that means all this is one more
loss for them until they really get it
going
that's the worst exactly they're gonna
go they're gonna go another four wins
and
everyone's gonna be like oh my gosh this
has never happened in history and
jamal like can you can we just quickly
touch on the fact that
jamal looks small on the court and he's
6'4
he's and he's playing like he's 7-4
he's not a small guy but he looks like a
little ninja
it's unbelievable i it's really fun to
watch them play right now
it is and and obviously they have been
counted out
so many damn times and they keep getting
off uh they keep getting off the mat
uh but here comes lebron and anthony
davis i thought they did have him
again i really thought that this was uh
this was it but
you know but i'm glad that you're you're
you're why but you're right it's great
to see them
in the bubble doing their thing and you
know
maybe again that they can be more of a
continue to be an inspiration to you and
everyone else there in the colorado area
keeptheflamealive.org
uh the jeff schifrin athlete resiliency
fund helps fuel u.s ski and snowboard
athletes olympic dreams
go there and donate right now it's been
a pleasure chat with you
i root for you all the time and um and
you're welcome here anytime call
we'll figure out what the time
difference is from germany maybe we'll
just catch up
okay sounds good thank you you got it
it's uh
us olympic and world ski champion seven
times over
two-time olympics five-time world
champion michaela shiffrin here